thanks to kiwico for helping support
this episode
hey crazies we like to think the earth
has a lot of texture
it's got tall mountains it's got low
valleys some of it is hard rock some of
it is soft grass quite a lot of it is
covered in water but if it could fit in
your hand what would it feel like
against your skin
[Music]
whenever i bring up the earth as a
sphere i inevitably get a certain kind
of comment
no not that kind i have comment filters
for those
i'm talking about the pedantic ones
the earth is actually an oblate spheroid
or if they're a little more elite the
earth is actually
technically speaking they're both kind
of right but not really
for the earth this one is probably the
largest deviation from a perfect sphere
it's bigger at the equator than between
the poles
the rotation flattens it out creating
something we call an equatorial bulge
get your mind out of the gutter
the difference isn't actually this big
though i've exaggerated it for clarity
seriously mind out of the gutter
the equatorial diameter is only 26 miles
bigger than the polar diameter it's
about 43 kilometers for all the metric
people out there
which might seem like a lot
but the entire earth is about 8 000
miles in diameter
the oblateness is only 0.3 percent
and like i said that's the largest
deviation from a perfect sphere
0.3 percent
it doesn't have much impact on texture
but it does give us a decent upper bound
something we've known for a long time is
that gravity varies from place to place
because the earth doesn't have a
perfectly uniform density
you might have even seen images like
this
sorry to burst your bubble but that's
also exaggerated
all you've got to do is take one look at
the scale the deviations are at most
around 360 feet or 110 meters
that's a hundred times smaller than
mountains and trenches
the geoid actually looks like this it's
basically just a sphere
human structures have a bigger impact on
the earth's texture than this
the geoid effect may be too small to
worry about but there are plenty of
larger features
mountains are tall and ocean trenches
are deep
let's try to get some perspective on how
big these things are
here are the rocky mountains in colorado
honestly this footage isn't doing it
justice they're huge
if you've never seen them before you
should it's it's a humbling experience
you don't even have to be good at hiking
i drove to this overlook it's right off
the road america
what were you doing all the way up there
in dress clothes oh oh we were getting
five year anniversary photos this past
summer this one's my favorite
awkward m sister took the pictures and
wait where was i
right mountains
they seem tall to us because we tend to
use ourselves as a reference but that
reference isn't going to serve us very
well today
this mountain has an elevation of 12 000
feet that's 2.3 miles or 3.7 kilometers
but that's only point zero three percent
of the diameter of the earth
that's one tenth of the earth's
oblateness it's pretty tiny
to be fair though there are higher
mountains
the highest in north america is easily
denali in alaska at twenty thousand
three hundred feet or three point eight
miles
but that's only point zero five percent
of the diameter of the earth mount
everest has the highest elevation in the
world 29 000 feet or 5.5 miles
but that's only 0.07
of the diameter of the earth
of course these numbers probably aren't
giving you much perspective
a scale model should help
no this one won't work the scale is 159
million to one which is a bit too small
for our needs we'll come back to it
later
when i was first planning this video i
thought about doing a one-to-one scale
unfortunately that would have put the
center of the earth in the pacific ocean
and i can't exactly send adventure clone
out on a boat for 15 seconds of footage
then i thought maybe a two to one scale
could work i even sent adventure clone
out to haze kansas to film a segment
about the core mantle boundary it put
the scaled center of the earth right
smack in the middle of san diego which
could have been the perfect opportunity
to collab with my friend diana you
probably know her as physics girl
speaking of which i should probably call
her and catch up
anyway something being fun to watch
doesn't necessarily mean it has
educational value
a two-to-one scale earth isn't actually
helpful for anyone's perspective it's
just too big
what we need is a scale large enough
that the mountains are obvious but small
enough that the earth isn't completely
impractical
how about a million to one
that's right around the scale you'd find
on a typical u.s state map
believe it or not this is all we had for
navigation when i was a kid
the horror
anyway let's go with colorado
at a scale of a million to one every
inch on this map is a million inches or
15.8 miles in the real state of colorado
or thanks to the metric system one scale
millimeter equals one real kilometer
gotta love that metric system
so how tall are the mountains on that
scale
visible but still pretty small this
colorado mountain had an elevation of 12
000 feet or 2.3 miles
in metric that's 3.7 kilometers
at a million to one scale that's 3.7
millimeters
that mountain looks like this
i mean look at this thing it's adorable
you're too cute yes you are did the
little baby mountain
remember denali the highest mountain in
north america
here it is at 6.2 millimeters
mount everest the highest mountain in
the world this is it at 8.8 millimeters
that's it that's as far from sea level
as you can get without flying
speaking of flying
scaling the atmosphere is going to be
trickier
the density of the atmosphere drops
gradually as you go up in altitude about
two-thirds of it is below the peak of
mount everest but the other one-third
goes up quite a ways
the drop-off is so gradual that there
really isn't a clear edge
but when has ambiguity ever stopped
humans from making categories am i right
the international definition for the
edge of space is a hundred kilometers up
on this scale that puts it at a hundred
millimeters that's way up here
the peaks of these mountains are nowhere
near what anyone would consider outer
space
so the atmosphere dwarfs the mountains
but the entire earth dwarfs the
atmosphere
on our map scale the center of the earth
is about 21 feet or 6.4 meters down
which i can't really show indoors it's
time to go outside
here's our same colorado map at a
million to one scale the center of the
earth would be 21 feet or 6.4 meters
below that the other side of the earth
is twice that distance away
my point is the earth is big
the entire atmosphere is a thin film
clinging to the surface of a giant space
rock and our highest mountains are only
a tenth of the height of that atmosphere
the earth is actually quite smooth
the real question is how smooth exactly
would it feel smooth if you were holding
the earth in your cosmic hand
my instincts say yes perfectly smooth
but let's check anyway
what actually matters for the texture of
the earth is the height of a mountain
compared to the surrounding mountains
most mountains don't have the ocean
right next to them they have other
mountains next to them
i suppose i could spend an entire week
making a spreadsheet full of mountain
elevations but i don't need to an order
of magnitude estimate should be enough
a quick glance at a map and we can see
mountain peaks vary from a half a mile
up to a couple miles
we round that to one mile and convert to
metric and scale 159 million to one we
get
10 micrometers
huh i mean that's small but i expected
that to be a lot smaller
can we feel that i don't know
research cologne
yes how sensitive is human touch i don't
know i'll check
thanks
whoa
in 2013 a team of swedish scientists put
nano scale ripples in the surface of
smooth materials then people ran their
dominant index finger over each surface
the team found that participants could
detect differences as small as 13
nanometers tall and 760 nanometers wide
which is kind of bonkers
that's a thousand times smaller than our
scaled mountains
for perspective on this scale we could
feel cars and houses
well assuming they were pretty isolated
and half a mile apart
and you were running your fingertips
over them
the paper also states that in the
absence of movement 0.2 millimeters is
actually the minimum detectable
imperfection which is larger than the
largest surface features on earth
so i guess the answer is yes we could
feel the mountains as long as we're
rubbing them
the earth's oblateness exaggerated the
earth's geoid exaggerated
if you were holding the earth in your
hand it would feel like a perfectly
smooth ball
maybe a little soft and a little wet but
that's it
but if you're rubbing it the precious
you could at least tell that some parts
of it were rougher than others
so would you want to be like galactus
and hold the earth in your hand please
share in the comments
that was a really creepy share in the
comments
i'm gonna do that again please share in
the comments
do it now pressus
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like ilya
yoshin who has been pledging at the
einsteinium level for over three years
that's a lot of support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
thanks again to kiwiko for helping
support this episode
kiwiko is a monthly subscription box
full of super cool hands-on projects
designed to expose kids to concepts in
stem and ships to more than 40 countries
they offer eight subscription lines each
catering to a different age group the
one i'm working on here is the eureka
crate for ages 14 and older but i'm
considering getting the koala grate for
my niece
each key we co-crate comes with all the
supplies you need for that month's
project i only had to grab a pair of
scissors to cut open the bags and trim
some zip ties
this crate even had extras for some of
the more fragile pieces just in case
the experience was engaging in very low
stress
it would be great for a kid or adult
that loves hands-on projects
when we teach kids to problem solve
innovate and create today who knows what
they'll do tomorrow and hey look at that
it works
if you're interested you can get 50 off
your first month for any crate by going
to kiwico.com
science asylum linked below in the
description
[Music]
the featured comment comes from
defenestrated23 who said imaginary is
the most unfortunate name in mathematics
i agree real and imaginary are such
terrible names i mean all numbers are
imaginary am i right anyway thanks for
watching